the row over post-brexit fishing rights
between france and britain is coming to
a head with the uk government saying
it's not working towards a deadline set
by the eu commission and ending today
to resolve the issue french fishermen
meanwhile are caught between a rock and
a hard place
in november french fishers temporarily
blocked three channel ports including
key hub calais disrupting cross-channel
ferry traffic for several hours the
fishers say britain is still not
honoring a post-brexit deal to allow
them to fish in uk waters if they can
prove they fished there in the past they
claim the uk has refused to recognize
fishing operations not validated by gps
but many of the operators have no gps
and used paper lockbox instead their
applications were rejected
we are leading these actions for the
remaining licenses that have not arrived
there are 150 missing for the french we
want to show the british that we are fed
up with always being pushed around
next week next week they say but we have
had enough and here we are taking action
the november protests were not confined
to the sea parallel to the calais
blockade fishers also prevented road
fright from entering the euro tunnel
causing long tail backs for a while
though short the protest sent a clear
message that there's plenty of scope for
disruption if the uk doesn't finally
ease its position on fishing licenses
let's get more of this from dw
correspondent lisa lewis in paris lisa a
deadline given by the eu to resolve the
issue is ending today and the uk
government says we don't care about any
deadlines how worked up is the french
government about this
the french are very angry about the
whole row really they're saying you know
if the uk doesn't act there's still
about a 100 license and slacking and 1
000 licenses have have been giving a
given out to french fishermen so the
french government says if you don't give
us the remaining licenses we will take
other action we will block british
vessels from
shoring and coming to to french ports
and selling their fish there we will
block
lorries coming over to sell their fish
we will increase our security checks uh
they're even threatening to revise
the the amount of electricity they are
sending to the uk and the french
government is also saying that they're
planning on addressing the partnership
council that is a uk eu committee
supposed to oversee the implementation
of the brexit
treaty so the treaty with which the uk
has left the european union mind you the
british side is also threatening to go
to that partnership council and impose
actions
sanctions on the french so it's a very
heated discussion indeed on both sides
lisa how likely is it that these
countermeasures will really be put in
place between and you mentioned it two
nations that used to be eu partners
absolutely well you know it's a heated
row but it's very political if you look
at the economic side of things fishing
only represents 1.0 percent of the
british gdp but the
british government is using this road to
show that they are standing their ground
in front of the eu especially the french
and france is using this to show you
know we're not letting them off the hook
easily leaving the eu is not an easy
thing obviously the french president
eman marco is looking ahead to the
looming presidential elections in about
four months and he wants to show that he
defends europe when it comes down to the
details though it's very likely that
both sides will try to find a compromise
the french government has even said that
if they are in the end still some
fishermen that are lacking licenses that
the french government will put money on
the table they're talking about 40 to 60
million euros so it looks like both
sides know that they will not get a
hundred percent of the what they're
asking for
and lisa speaking of the fishermen what
impact has this uh dispute been having
on the french fishing industry
well as i said they're about 100
licenses that are lacking so what's
happening really what fishermen have
been explaining to me is that you know
lots of fish they that comes to
french waters to actually breed there
but then once the fish is grown they
leave to go to uk waters and the
fishermen have been telling me that now
these coming months are very crucial for
them actually in the uk waters so if
they can't go to uk water waters because
they're lacking a license they're losing
our most of their income and they're
really saying if we can't use these few
months ahead of us then we're likely to
go bankrupt we're talking about 100
licenses but the french government has
said that each license eats fishermen
and represents about three or four jobs
on land so maybe about 500 jobs the
french government is ready to jump in
but many of these fishermen have been
fishing all their lives and for
generations actually so it will have a
huge impact on them
lisa lewis in paris thank you
you